in his speech to Russian lawmakers
President Putin blamed the West for the
war even though it was Russia that
launched a full-scale invasion of
Ukraine Charlie daggers and Ukraine's
Capital Kiev with more on Putin's speech
and the impact of the war on ukrainians
Charlie good morning
good morning to you Nate yeah in Putin's
World Ukraine started the war in fact he
goes further to say the West started it
it's the same sort of theme he used a
year ago this week to justify The
Invasion and he doubled down saying
Russia cannot be defeated
[Applause]
[Music]
State of the Union annual speech Russian
president Vladimir Putin took aim at the
West for escalating the war and its
support for Ukraine
the more long-range systems that come
into Ukraine he said the further will be
forced to move that threat away from our
borders
that's exactly what Ukrainian troops are
preparing for in Coupe ask this battered
eastern city less than 10 miles from
russian-controlled territory once home
to around 30 000 people it's now a shell
of what it was before it was captured by
Russian forces liberated in September
following a ferocious Ukrainian
counter-offensive residents here tell us
there has been an increase in the number
of explosions that they've heard over
the past few days and defense officials
tell us that the Russians may be intent
on recapturing coupons
volunteers Soldier nazari says the
Russians are using all the weapons at
their disposal
everything everything
he said every day everything but we're
used to this and we keep the defense but
it is a grim existence with the local
economy in tatters families struggle to
afford food relying on volunteers who
serve one warm meal a day
for many people it is the only one
opportunity to get food Valentina Julia
says we have no gas we're being bombed
there were eight missile attacks on our
city the day before yesterday
house was destroyed she came back to
collect some belongings warmer clothes
she's not staying are you worried that
the Russians may try to take kupiansk
again
no but we're afraid it's very loud here
they are shelling shelling and shelling
always they are shelling Ukrainian
forces may be dug in better equipped to
hold koopy ants this time but residents
once again face a stark decision
evacuation and homelessness or hunkering
down to ride out the approaching storm
now since we've returned from cupions
even more of the surrounding territory
has been recaptured by Russian forces as
Ukraine marks one year since the
invasion began this week people across
the country are bracing for what may
come tarika
Charlie dagato force and Keith thank you